oh my God this post blew my mind is
there something going on with Ethan's
basement I remember Ethan said on the
show that Alfredo refuses to go in the
basement that's still true one day
Alfredo stopped going in the basement he
will not spend any time there he used to
come down with us used to love being
down there with us one day he refuses he
will not go and if you carry him down he
runs right back up he will not be down
there so listen to this is it possible
that there's something unhealthy in the
basement that Alfredo can smell for
example a quick Google search says that
mole can cause kidney problems along
with other issues dogs can smell a
certain type of mold it would explain
why Shredder is experiencing health
problems but not Alfredo also Ethan's
been been in the basement a lot and has
weird blood tests this blew my mind and
not so there was an issue because the
basement's underground when it was
raining a lot that some of the wall one
wall in particular I know was getting
saturated with water from the house